et un premier véhicule donc le véhicule
qui viennent de Perpignan en direction
de Villeneuve de larao mais qui s'arrête
ils sont au niveau du passage du piéton
puis ma femme qui s'engage Yanis qui est
précède donc deux petits pas aller Yanis
à 8 ans donc ils sont bien engagés sur
le passage piéton et un véhicule qui
vient de droite conduite par
Marie-Christine qui vient à toute
vitesse et qui et qui elle ne s'arrête
pas donc on est dans une zone 30 elle
est pratiquement au double de la vitesse
donc le tape le choc est tellement
violent que Yanis se projeter en l'air
ça tape le port brise et puis le
projette de 6 mètres plus loin elle a
encore le temps de freiner même si elle
tape sur le passage de piéton elle a je
veux dire comme tout être humain à ce
moment-là on appuie sur la [ __ ] de
frein et puis non Marie-Christine décide
de s'enfuir
et pour s'enfuir elle roule sur Yanis
donc Yanis s'est blessé par terre vivant
mais elle achève tout simplement
donc elle roule sur lui elle traîne sur
plus de 22 mètres
et ensuite elle roule encore avec la
roue arrière donc elle regarde pas la
rétroviseur quand on lui pose la
question pourquoi vous ne vous êtes pas
arrêté pour porter assistance elle dit
non je l'ai vu qu'il bougeait bon
j'ai eu du monde caler vers lui
et puis elle s'enfuit elle s'en va tout
simplement
c'est ce qui se passe dans un premier
temps et
bien sûr il y a des témoins sur place
qui relèvent la plaque d'immatriculation
elle est partie je crois 600 mètres plus
loin dans un espèce de petit chemin et
puis elle appelle la gendarmerie alors
disant je viens de toucher un petit
garçon
en fait elle appelle aussi son fils que
j'aime dans donc c'est tout un Big Mac
qui rentre dans cette histoire et bien
quand elle laisse yanisateur
elle le laisse à l'agonie quoi il va
décider quelques heures plus tard il
hurle de douleur à ce moment-là
les côtes cassé le thorax et les poumons
explosent des plaies de partout il y a
de votre femme qui court vers lui
pendant 22 mètres elle lui supplie de
freiner tout simplement Yanis quand il
est sous le châssis à savoir que c'est
un marque Citroën ils ont mesuré entre
le sol et le châssis il y a 16 cm encore
aujourd'hui je me demande comment la
fait pour le faire passer sous la roue
avant et ressortir sur le roue arrière
donc finalement
c'est parce qu'il a tout simplement été
broyé
il y a toutes les côtes qui cassent le
thorax il y a les deux clavicules il est
scalpé
les poumons explosent les deux jours du
fémur complètement coupé une cicatrice
qui part de tout le long de la cuisse et
j'en passe j'ai pas envie de tout
expliquer donc le petit sur 22 mètres
plus loin mais il a encore vivant
ce qui est énorme c'est que pendant 22
mètres il a senti tout son corps qui se
cassait qu'il est arrivé à parler vous
allez arriver il pouvait plus parler
parce qu'il avait donc le pommeau
explosé donc il gémissait j'ai mis ces
deux douleurs mais on entend des crier
tout le temps vous rendez compte la
douleur pour la maman pour les deux
filles
qui ont assisté à ça et
ce qui m'étonne encore aujourd'hui c'est
comment Marie-Christine elle a l'enfant
sous le châssis à moins de mettre
l'entend pas elle entend pas sa mère
quand elle crie
et puis cette personne qui est bizarre
aussi c'est que une heure après elle
ressort de la gendarmerie
sans même avoir de compte avant vous
Hakim n'était pas là c'est une dame qui
vous prévient l'accident par téléphone
elle tente d'être rassurante
vous sentez que
sentez que c'est très grave à ce moment
là ou pas complètement donc on m'appelle
oui en fait mon épouse était dans une
état tel bon tout le monde veut
comprendre pourquoi donc elle était en
panique mais ce qui est formidable parce
qu'il faut lui reconnaître quand même ce
courage à ce petit qui n'a que 8 ans il
a qu'une main qui bouge sa mère est sur
lui
laissez le protéger excla ça reste et
puis le petit qui passe la main qui lui
tapote la tête comme pour la rassurer
c'est simplement fou j'ai une personne
qui qui m'appelle donc qui prend le
téléphone de ma femme il dit écoutez il
y a un accident vous inquiétez pas il y
a ce moment avec le petit
mot la maman elle est pas en état de
parler bon passez-moi moins mon fils
donc le dimanche chérie à ton papa
est-ce que tu veux lui parler il essaie
de communiquer mais en fait j'ai mis
à tel point que je sens que c'est grave
en réalité ça me glace à l'intérieur je
comprends que c'est vraiment grave donc
je vais au lac de Villeneuve-de-la-Raho
et puis arrivé sur place il y a full il
y a des camions des pompiers des
gendarmes un peu partout les petites qui
étaient tenues par des personnes puis je
rentre dans une commune de pompiers je
voyage dedans vous savez dans les
espèces de bâche là qu'ils ont de
premiers secours les pompiers
la proche de lui je fais Yanis c'est
papa ça va il arrive encore à s'exprimer
mais c'est faible d'une toute petite
voix mais vraiment faible il me dit ça
va
quand vous savez qu'il avait tout était
détruire à l'intérieur jusqu'au bout il
aurait été quoi je suis petit
et bien
voilà j'arrive je suis prévenu quand
j'arrive on me dit c'est gravissime
c'est très très grave à ce moment là je
sais pas que c'est une dame qui l'a
écrasé qui s'est enfui on me parle d'un
accident
et bien
sortant du camion il fait un premier
arrêt cardiaque
au bout d'un moment ils arrivent à lui
faire repartir le cœur
donc quand le cœur repart il part aux
urgences on suit le camion des pompiers
et refera une autre attaque de nouveau
une autre crise cardiaque un arrêt
cardiaque et puis à nouveau ils
arriveront ils arriveront à lui faire
repartir le cœur
réalité il lui a injecté ce qu'on a nous
comme ça dans le corps puisqu'il a fallu
drainer les poumons et en même temps
rééjecter le sang mais il a combattu la
il s'est vraiment accroché jusqu'à 4h du
matin ça a été ça a été un long combat
mais en combat puisque les médecins
viennent vous informer tout est cassé
que Yanis est vivant aux alentours de
22h à minuit on vous dit que Yanis ça va
être transféré par hélicoptère pour être
transféré à Montpellier il y avait un
espoir encore à ce moment-là
complètement
et puis ils avaient injecté enfin tout
ce qu'on a comme plaquettes adrénaline
toutes les drogues possibles mais il
acceptait tout dans un premier temps ils
ont cru
et ils ont même fait un céphalogramme
donc je vous ai dit tout ce qui était
cassé dans le travail de reconstruction
reconstruction pardon énormément il me
dit que si le cerveau est touché et bien
il dirait pas plus loin puisque la
fatalité serait que ça servirait pas
grand chose bien une heure après ils
reviennent ils me disent que non le
cerveau n'a rien du tout il n'est pas
touché donc ils avaient bon espoir
j'appelle un hélicoptère de Montpellier
avec des docteurs qui viennent sur place
l'idée c'était qui partent ensuite à
Montpellier
ils sont toutes mieux adaptés à
Montpellier à Perpignan
je vais chez moi
prendre un peu de sucre pour ensuite
suivre et partir sur Montpellier
on m'appelle on me dit écoutez un peu
plus transporter passion vous expliquera
en fait j'arrivais pour qu'il m'apprenne
que c'était plus on pouvait plus sauver
donc sa vie s'arrête 4h du matin il
déclare la fin de vidéo à Nice
à 7h on a le gendarme qui nous appelle
pour porter plainte
puis quand on arrive sur place
on apprend que le délai de qui a eu un
délit de fuite mais que le délu de fuite
n'est pas
n'est pas retenu qui serait requalifiée
bon comprenez pas trop pourquoi c'est
c'est donc la gendarmerie qui vous
appelle le gendarme qui est en charge
d'enquêter
qui m'avait laissé
du matin on nous dit allez pour porter
plainte encore et donc vous arrivez et
vous dit que déjà là il y a
Marie-Christine donc la femme qui a
Christine qui
est en début de fuite je savais pas trop
ce qui s'était passé on a encore nous en
train de pas placer en garde à vue elle
reste seulement une heure au
commissariat avec son permis en poche
complètement
elle ressort au bout d'une heure on se
demande pourquoi d'ailleurs elle n'est
pas mise en garde à vue directement
et elle sera entendue qu'au mois d'avril
donc de février en avril bien entendu
elle a eu le temps d'être briefé et puis
de alors le jour de changer complètement
de version ce qui est fou c'est que le
jour de l'enterrement de votre fils il
décide de faire une reconstitution donc
forcément votre femme témoin et n'est
pas présente n'est pas présente il faut
une reconstitution sans votre femme
complètement donc là aussi c'est le
premier témoin qui était sur place mais
alors il nous demande en fait de laisser
le corps pour faire la Constitution
pardon le corps pour essayer d'établir
la
vitesse puisqu'il n'y a pas de trace de
frein le frein à aucun moment
il est envoyé en autopsie et puis avec
l'expert donc
le choc qui est sur le véhicule plus ce
qui a
le choc qui a surréné entre parenthèses
mais il détermine qu'elle était
pratiquement au double de la vitesse
autorisée donc ça c'est à dire d'expert
alors pourquoi ils n'ont pas retenu le
délit de fit Yuli c'est parce qu'après
avoir percuté une enfant la conductrice
a continué sa route et à très néganise
sur 22 mètres ce que vous avez dit des
témoins sur le burn out sont alors des
signes de la main et elle finit par
s'arrêter 600 mètres plus loin
donc à ce moment là et bien elle appelle
la gendarmerie ce qui considère eux
comme étant les secours mais à aucun
moment l'appelle les pompiers ce n'est
pas elle qui fait intervenir les
pompiers ou la SAMU en réalité elle
appelle la gendarmerie
mais rappelle son fils qui lui gendarme
et quand les gendarmes arrivent sur
place mais ils constatent que son fils
est présent et qui leur déclare qu'il
est lui-même
ensuite elle part en gendarmerie une
heure après elle retourne chez elle
alors les mois passent
sont bizarrement écartés la vitesse de
délit de fuite la non-assistance à
personne en danger selon la version
donnée aux journalistes la conductrice
aurait percuté le fils d'Akim après
avoir été à ébloui par le soleil et à
continuer sa route parce qu'elle pensait
avoir percuté un volatile c'est la
version qui est qui est donnée elle
appelle les forces de l'ordre mais pas
les secours elle dit qu'elle va appeler
son fils qui sera présent sur place
quelques minutes après ce qu'on nous
dites puisque son fils et gendarme
est-ce que vous avez eu l'occasion de
discuter avec elle jamais jamais le
moindre remords pour s'excuser ou même
pas une fleur sur sur la tombe de Yanis
mais vraiment c'est rien du tout quoi
l'enquête de personnalité lui demande
comment elle se sent depuis bah elle dit
qu'elle arrivait à dormir et que sur moi
déjà ça on y pense des fois
occasionnellement
voilà ça vous décrit à peu près le genre
de personne que ça donc elle est dans le
déni tout le temps elle dit que c'est
lui qui a déboulé sur la route alors
qu'il est sur le passage du piéton
et puis enfin plein de versions la
première c'est la c'est celle au moment
où la gendarmerie elle dit bien qu'elle
a tapé un petit garçon donc je pense
qu'à ce moment-là
elle dit complètement ce qui s'est passé
à partir du moment où elle part en
gendarmerie et qu'elle ressort puis
rentre tout et ses versions qui sont
j'ai envie de dire de l'ordre du délire
on peut plus la suivre on comprend plus
rien alors on va maintenant parler du
procès et merci à mettre Malawi d'être
avec nous qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit le
jour de son procès quelle est sa version
alors moi de prime abord j'aimerais dire
déjà que il est pas question en tout cas
moi j'assiste aujourd'hui monsieur mon
client sur ce plateau c'est un
témoignage qui a vocation en tout cas à
aller comme vous l'avez compris vers une
mobilisation et que en tout cas c'est
pas mon but de faire un procès voilà
d'accord c'est important
la première chose que je en tout cas la
seconde que j'aimerais indiquer c'est
que
c'est un drame il est réalisé et puis on
pourrait presque dire c'est ainsi il
faut qu'une enquête soit diligente
qu'elle soit à la hauteur du drame c'est
la première chose moi en tout cas en
tant qu'avocat aujourd'hui de Monsieur
et de ses proches ce que je déplore
c'est plutôt la réponse pénale qui a été
importée c'est à dire que c'est une
enquête il y a pas eu d'instruction il y
a pas eu d'instruction et donc
l'instruction si vous voulez ça permet
quand même je pense
que tout le monde sait à peu près ce que
ça permet ça permet par le truchement
des avocats de la défense et des parties
civils de faire des demandes d'actes et
donc de demander un magistrat à quel
juge d'instruction un certain nombre de
choses des idées rattaques qui sont oui
ou non acceptés oui ou non accueilli et
là ce qui laisse quand même goût
extrêmement amer à ce dossier c'est
l'idée qu'il y a eu une enquête et
qu'ensuite une sorte de téléportation au
procès ou en réalité nous sommes un peu
devant le fait accompli les demandes
d'actes nous devons le code de procédure
pénale nous le permet mais nous devons
les faire au seuil de l'audience
et donc en réalité aujourd'hui on a fait
une demande d'acte au seuil de
l'audience ça a été renvoyé au fond je
vais pas rentrer dans la technique
judiciaire ça a été renvoyé au fond au 9
novembre mais je pense qu'il luttait
beaucoup plus utile en tout cas c'est
mon sentiment je suis le père de mes
propos que cet acte et que cette demande
en tout cas au lieu d'être accepté voilà
elle aurait dû être réalisée selon moi
en amont du procès puisque là on a déjà
eu le procès au fond et donc un procès
au fond vidé de la substance d'une
demande d'acte par une des parties pour
moi ça n'a pas vraiment de sens alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit aujourd'hui le
procès c'est quoi sa version et bien le
jour du procès c'était une boule de feu
qui lui serait tombé dessus
volatile voilà encore une version de
plus vous assistez je crois à la
quatrième version alors ce qui ressort
dans le processus que nous a dit maître
il y a un instant c'est que l'enquête
n'était pas complète
les avocats apparemment
ce qu'ils ont ils ont essayé de mettre
la con face à ces contradictions mais
ça n'a pas ça n'a pas eu lieu un Gilles
non non il y a pas eu d'émotion est-ce
qu'il frappe vraiment c'est que par
rapport à votre témoignage bouleversant
on a effectivement une enquête bâclée
Cyril même le médecin légiste voulait
des expertises complémentaires ça a été
refusé d'accord l'enquête a été très
vite le procès rapide et on a
l'impression quand même vous parliez du
fils gendarme de cette conductrice en
relisant le dossier je sais pas si c'est
votre avis on a quand même l'impression
que c'est conductrice la justice a voulu
la protéger alors
qu'il ressort du dossier c'est je suis
complètement pour depuis le début je
connais pas enfin j'ai jamais entendu
dire que
une responsable de la mort de quelqu'un
sur un passage piéton qui lui là il a il
a toute la priorité donc un passage de
piéton ça reste par définition pour le
piéton donc c'est protégé ensuite
l'écraser s'enfuir pas porter assistance
arriver à un excès de vitesse avec
toutes ces tout ça ça gravante qu'elle
ressortent une heure après de la
gendarmerie oui elle est protégée
clairement il y a pas de souci alors qui
a bénéficié de temps d'indulgence je
connais pas alors le procureur
c'est sûr c'est c'est c'est fou voilà
les gens qui nous regardent ce soir
toutes les personnes qui nous regardent
le procureur qui accuse la conductrice
de mentir requiert 50 prisons avec
sursis c'est la déception là tout
simplement complètement alors ce délai
de fuite qui n'apparaît pas dans le dans
l'enquête mais il est remis par le
procureur les enquêteurs qui mettent en
avant le non-assistance le procureur qui
l'enlève on comprend rien du tout dans
ce dossier voyez et puis quand il remet
les deux lits de fuite on voit qu'il
remet quand même quelques circonstances
s'aggravantes à savoir qu'au bout de
deux circonstances d'après le code pénal
exactement
à un homicide involontaire et plus de
deux circonstances agrémentes c'est au
moins 10 ans de prison complètement et
puis
il demande que 5 ans de sursis pour pour
aller aux plus simples 0 jours de prison
exactement
alors justement elle n'a même pas
d'amande du tout pour l'excès de vitesse
ou la [ __ ] rien du tout au niveau pénal
rien du tout rien n'a été demandé donc
là elle n'a rien eu zéro elle était
épargnée
c'est le 9 novembre la délibéré peut
changer mais honnêtement je n'y crois
pas du tout d'accord quand on boit
l'évolution depuis le début son
permis annuler même pas pour le moment
on verra
elle ne peut pas conduire je ne sais pas
pour 18 mois ils ont demandé un retrait
pour 18 mois déménager à vous aménager
il va falloir attendre le neuf mais si
vous me permettez juste
très rapidement c'est un peu redondant
ce que j'ai dit mais l'instruction ça
c'est très important dans ce type de
dossier je vais vous donner un exemple
il y a pas eu de confrontation par
exemple entre la maman qui était sur les
lieux et la conductrice moi je dis pas
que on peut attendre d'une instruction
l'impossible et très souvent nous sommes
déchus dans des drames similaires ce que
je dis c'est qu'il faut laisser la
possibilité aux gens de s'exprimer et
quand on n'a pas la possibilité de le
faire encore une fois par
l'intermédiaire de son avocat ou en
étant entendu par le juge d'instruction
en tant que participe c'est extrêmement
frustrant complètement alors on est même
pas le droit de faire appel non pourquoi
en réalité nous participe on ne dépend
du procureur vous avez bien compris et
puis là je fais le pari qui ne fera pas
appel
depuis le début c'est ce qu'on appelle
des enquêtes à charge et à décharge pour
le coup ça a été l'enquête à décharge
c'est ça et complètement décharge donc
c'est arrivé au tribunal le 28 on
attendait de réponse penser qu'au
tribunal et bien ce serait autre chose
c'est quand même pas grave parce qu'elle
a fait m'écrase pas un enfant qui
partait pour s'enfuir donc c'est très
très grave dans le droit fil de ce qu'il
disait on peut pas faire appel du
dispositif pénal mais on peut faire
appel du dispositif civil mais voilà
mais les civils c'est autre chose ça
c'est pour les assurances on est
d'accord cette histoire est complètement
incroyable Gilles donc la mort de Yanis
ça vaut 0 jours de prison
c'est ça c'est
fou Gilles elle a été placée sous
contrôle judiciaire effectivement pas de
prison et quand quand vous là vous
demandez une mobilisation et on sent
bien enfin on a tous envie d'être elle
est-ce que vous voudriez vous trouver un
moyen pour que le procès soit cassé qui
est un supplément d'information et pour
que la faire repartent à zéro c'est ça
le président peut décider à tout moment
le complément d'enquête c'est ça que
vous souhaitez mais je l'invite à nous
le donner c'est quand même des articles
qui est sur le code pénal donc c'est un
droit nous les victimes je veux savoir
comment mon fils est mort si c'est au
premier août deuxième chose je veux
savoir pourquoi il a écrasé aussi
pourquoi la page freiner qu'est-ce qu'il
doit faire
on a une enquête de gendarmerie
l'enquête de gendarmerie je vais
peut-être être très méchant avec ce que
je veux dire parce que quand même
quelques quelques experts mais ça
ressemble à une enquête comme c'est un
vol de voiture vous voyez c'est quand
même un enfant qui a été tué c'est une
enquête criminelle on ne peut pas faire
la moitié d'une enquête et l'autre
moitié là il se de côté donc pour ma
part oui c'est pas cette enquête il y a
des vides partout il manque un
complément d'enquête quand je demande
mon dossier médical je sais que le
cerveau n'a pas été touché
et puis j'entends dire que de toute
façon premier choc il aurait succomber
parce que le cerveau avait des légions
telles qu'il aurait pas pu survivre en
réalité le cerveau n'a rien du tout j'ai
demandé mon dossier médical pour pouvoir
confronter celui qui a décidé que
premier choc qui serait mort donc je
veux pas en dire plus on me donne pardon
c'est important c'est que on me donne le
dossier que le 21 septembre je le
demande en avril par le biais de mes
avocats en me le donnant le 21 septembre
pour pouvoir justement débattre sur le
dossier sur le fond sur le parce que ça
pourrait impliquer aussi qui est une
remise en cause de la qualification
d'accord jusqu'au passage du python on
va dire que c'est un volontaire mais à
partir du moment qu'elle prend la
décision de s'enfuir donc d'écraser
l'enfant je vous laisse imaginer ce que
ça peut être il y a eu volonté de
s'enfuir toujours et puis
on me dit c'est trop tard
attendez vous me donnez le dossier le 21
comment voulez-vous que ce soit trop
tard il fallait me le donner avant donc
voilà là aussi il y avait matière à
débattre ça aussi dans le complément
d'enquête on pourrait le faire remonter
et puis j'attends la bonne volonté de ce
qu'ils ont encore les cartes en main
voilà c'est un peu c'est un peu ce qui
est frustrant au niveau c'est beaucoup
même frustrant je pense pas qu'une
enquête
criminelle ce soit fait en deux mois
aussi en deux mois c'était bouclé bâclé
puisque je reviens ce qu'on nous
explique depuis des jours et des jours
aussi complètement on nous donne le jour
du tribunal et voilà il y a parfois les
enquêtes peuvent aller très vite c'est
ça dans des cas comme ça
on veut pas de d'enquête rapide on veut
pas on veut pas de justice du moyen-âge
on veut une justice de maintenant moi je
passe d'un accident de la route qui
aurait pu arriver à n'importe qui c'est
un accident de la route je passe à Dan
accident de la route à quelqu'un qui
s'en va 600 mètres plus loin pour
téléphone à son fils gendarme qui a tapé
un volatile moi si je tape volatile le
bruit que ça a fait dans le pare-choc le
bruit que ça fait sur le pare-brise je
m'arrête net même si c'est un oiseau et
je regarde où il est l'oiseau il est où
l'oiseau que j'ai tapé c'est un minimum
c'est pas pour un volatile dans votre
douleur je suis à 100 %. il y a pas de
mots et là bizarrement l'enquête rapide
après on va nous expliquer voilà que
mais il y a le 9 il y avait 9 novembre
il y a un truc le 9 novembre vous
attendez un truc
peut-être que Monsieur Dupont-Moretti va
regarder l'émission Ce soir et peut-être
qu'il va pouvoir sortir
par des députés qui ont pris qui
connaissent le dossier qui l'ont
interpellé j'espère qu'il a répondu ou
pas du tout pour le moment j'ai pas de
réponse alors s'il a fait il a dû parler
avec son collègue mais je suis pas au
courant j'aimerais bien qu'il intervient
vraiment un message de force il nous
regarde ça mais ça serait bien que Eric
Dupond-Moretti Vienne sur le splato
est-ce qu'on a beaucoup de dossiers à
voir avec le 6 et s'il vient comme ça je
ferai de la République à Paris mais
faudrait qu'il y a une décision qui a
été prise on m'a invité à venir pour la
manifestation de Yanis voilà donc vous
voyez ça a touché tellement de monde
cette injustice et puis à ce niveau là
il y aura quand même pas mal de
personnes qui sont au niveau politique
qui veulent en être donc je l'ai vu
aussi sur la toile il y aura un
rassemblement le 6 et puis j'espère que
ça réunira beaucoup de
donc ça fait mal à chaque fois de
reparler sur mais ça le mérite si vous
voulez que ça commence à voilà on en
parle il y a une injustice
se bat depuis des semaines et des
semaines comme un fou il fait tout avec
depuis février mais vraiment et je vous
le dis il fait tout moi je l'ai
rencontré une fois il va partout il fait
tout il essaie d'interpeller tout le
monde pour qu'on puisse se pencher sur
cette affaire il sur les réseaux aussi
il a tout fait pour son fils pour sa
famille et aujourd'hui il ne peut pas
accepter une telle décision de justice
et on peut le comprendre et on espère
comme je vous dis que le garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice peut-être
nous regarde ce soir et qui donnera une
réponse à Hakim ou qui se penchera sur
ce dossier en tout cas à qui me joue
vous avez été
incroyable parce que je sais que ça fait
des mois que vous le monde parce que
c'est un peu la force
je vous ai dit comment il se comporter
Yanis devant la mort
il a rassuré son père et sa mère
je peux pas reculer
je lui fais une promesse c'est que
j'irai jusqu'au bout il y aura justice
il le faut il faut pas la justice je
peux pas penser autrement le 6 ben ça a
généré si vous voulez un telen de
solidarité
au travers du fait que c'est la justice
sur les cinq codes pénal qui est là pour
donner aux victimes le droit d'exister
parce que même mort il a encore des
droits cet enfant donc le droit à la
justice c'est ce que je réclame après je
pense pas qu'on ne veuille pas lui
donner la justice pour le coup là j'ai
l'impression qu'on protège
Marie-Christine à tel point qu'on fait
fille de la mort de Yanis et ben non non
ça va pas être possible je pense que
j'appelle à ce qui est énormément de
personnes qui viennent pour demander
justice mais ce qui est tout le
contraire de la vengeance qu'on se
trompe pas Gilles est-ce que le dossier
peut être ouvert ou pas franchement là
c'est une affaire d'humanité et l'appel
au garde des sceaux c'est ça il faut que
lui maintenant agisse pour qu'il y ait
pas de jugement le neuf et qui est une
vraie enquête c'est pas possible parce
que c'est pour la mémoire de Yanis là
c'est même pas de la procédure c'est que
il suffit simplement que la justice dise
on n'a pas assez bien travaillé qu'on le
reconnaisse et qui a un supplément c'est
ce va vous demander et c'est ce que tout
le monde c'est ce que la justice
française doit Yannis franchement suffit
il suffit qu'il donne faim pour ma part
c'est ce que j'en pense j'espère qu'il
me dira pas donc le truc c'est que ce
soit juste une instruction qui
reprennent cette et qui l'instruise qui
fasse intervenir tous les experts le
médecin légiste demande à ce qui est un
complément d'enquête pour détermine la
cause réelle de la mort on va dans ce
sens aussi nous les parents on demande
si on est demandeur pour savoir et puis
on a une réponse aussi qui a été
terrible à quoi ça va vous servir de
savoir
le procureur qui demande les 50 de
sursis t'as pas de raison de cacher la
vérité c'est exactement le procureur 5
minutes avant puisque si vous voulez
c'est un espèce de jeu de rôle c'est
l'avant-dernier à parler et ensuite il y
a la défense qui parle depuis intervenir
déjà du mal à intervenir avant il me dit
ben écoutez
l'homicide puisqu'on parle de l'homicide
c'est pas un accident c'est l'homicide
involontaire et passible de 10 ans de
prison il me le dit ce que je lui fais
remarquer qu'il a quand même pas retenu
de mon assistance et dans la foulée me
dit c'est dix ans de prison monsieur
je demande 50 sursis il faut savoir si
le code pénal il y a 10 ans de prison il
me montre que pour lui c'est pas
nécessaire donc avec assorti tout
simplement de sursis pas de mise en
détention et 18 mois de retrait de
permis aménageable
qu'est-ce qu'on attend qu'elle recule la
prochaine fois le crime il est pas
suffisamment grave donc je fais encore
un appel puisque je pense que c'est
vraiment important que les gens se
mobilisent on l'a vu sur la toile
c'est au Québec c'est c'est en Belgique
c'est en Suisse en Algérie c'est au
Maroc c'est partout en France il reste
que quelques personnes qui pourraient
être déterminants dans cette histoire
vous voyez il suffit qu'ils accordent le
complément d'enquête c'est un enfant qui
a été tué c'est pas un chat c'est pas un
oiseau et bien on n'est pas des
accessoires alors qui donne cette
enquête et puis on verra ensuite moi je
suis pour la justice pour le coup là ça
ressemble à tout mais pas une vraie
justice c'est une enquête de gendarmerie
merci en tout cas merci beaucoup à qui
mais bravo
[Applaudissements]